lire les symptômes que tu as aujourd'hui
par rapport à ce que tu as eu la
dernière fois c'est désormais possible
vous pouvez dorénavant consulter un
médecin sans quitter votre domicile
une expérience inédite en martinique qui
a pu tester cette patiente qui a
souhaité rester anonyme
depuis son smartphone en direct en
visioconférence elle peut désormais
faire état de ses symptômes et de ses
ressentis pour le médecin ce nouvel
outil est une réelle évolution pour la
prise en charge des patients la
téléconsultation permet un échange
sécurisé d'effectuer un suivi des
pathologies et d'adresser directement
l'ordonance aux patients en cette
période d'épidémie de covile 19 cela
permet aussi de limiter les déplacements
à risques en respectant des règles de
confinement moi j'étais je pense porte
celle pendant deux semaines raison pour
laquelle j'ai complètement fermée
comprend puisque je n'avais pas du tout
envie d'être contaminantes pour les
patients
première chose deuxième chose on peut ça
nous permet pas de répondre quand même à
une demande malgré tout s'il échange
d'informations relatives à la santé sur
internet plus effrayer certains pour
autant pas de panique ce nouveau service
numérique est sécurisé et répond aux
normes imposent en la matière par le
ministère de la santé sur tout ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est quand même la
vidéo elle n'est pas enregistrée donc en
réalité lorsqu'on fait une vidéo
en gros la seconde d'après ça et passer
la seconde avant donc en matière il n'y
a pas de risque que la vidéo soit soient
sauvegardés en tout cas ça c'est ça
c'est un premier point
et puis après les données vraiment en
donnant ses et rédaction ça reste sur le
site donc sur les serveurs hds quand je
précisais donc protégé selon les
les demandes du ministère une innovation
technologique rendue possible grâce à
l'ingénierie et à la réactivité des
jeunes martiniquais à travers la
plateforme clicquot dock depuis la mise
en place du confinement cette start up
de cinq employés travaillent nuit et
jour sans subvention mettre au point
cette télé consultation
on a commencé depuis lundi et en
améliorant au fur et à mesure et pour
proposer vraiment un outil qui soit
complet et qui permettent de faire la
téléconsultation de fer ordonnance
sécurisée de pouvoir faire des paiements
si besoin pour pouvoir avoir un procès
ce qui est très simple pour les patients
la plateforme accessible via un
ordinateur ou via un smartphone connecté
à internet
à ce jour un peu plus de soixante cinq
professionnels de santé en martinique
sont déjà référencés pour la
téléconsultation